all right cassie
cassie where are you from we're talking
i am from pomona california
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents when you were a kid um
yes my family are still my life but i
don't talk to them really because
yeah long story but i don't want to
really talk about it right now
alcoholics pretty much and tell me about
uh your childhood how was it my
childhood was good i was raised right
but i continued to do wrong that's my
choices you know what i mean
but i'm trying to change that it's a new
year and my new year's revolution is to
finish something that i started finish
my accomplishments
and you know reach my goals what do you
what do you want to do this year
what i want to do this year i want to um
get my own place
and i want to get my kids back and
i just want to do good in life you know
how many kids you got i got two
how old my son's five years old my
daughter is one
and is the dad in the picture no he's
not
so you're working are you working figaro
street
i don't work no streets you do it over
the internet
i don't do internet either what do you
do i just do my
my whatever my mind tells me to do
do you work as a prostitute no you don't
no
what are we doing here well what am i
doing here well i used to
but um you know i have regulars you know
i like to be a nasty girl sometimes rare
and do guys pay you for money sometimes
to do that sometimes yeah
just some yeah
how much do they pay you um depending on
what they want
what's the nastiest thing they've asked
for
cip what's cit [ __ ] in [ __ ]
oh is that right yeah bbvj
bareback [ __ ] all that you know and
you do this sometimes
sometimes
i i it's been a long time since i've
done it though you know i don't really
put myself out there like that
unless that it's a regular you know what
i mean like i don't
how much how much does a c whatever or a
bb
whatever like 600 600 yeah
sometimes more than that sometimes
thousand dollars whatever
that's a risky way oh that's too much
sometimes sometimes they do like um
yeah 600. it's a risky way to make
make a living i mean yeah it really is
i've been through a lot of stuff you
know
like what's the crazy stuff you've been
doing okay well having pomona and this
guy is relate
and this guy he said he's gonna give me
some money right so he's reaching his
pocket
in the car with him and he's trying to
find like a dark spot and then we go in
the car and he finds a dark spot
finally and then he like actually i said
okay give me my money
like not trying to be rude or not things
i'm not a rude person but he's like
um i said okay you can have my money
first you know and he's all like um
yeah sure and then he reaches in his
pocket
by the driver door and then he um
pulls a knife out and i'm like sitting
like this i don't want to put my legs up
like that right now
or should i no no okay well i'm sitting
like this in the
in the passenger seat and then like he
he put a knife to my neck
right so i'm like pushing him towards
the windshield and like
kicking him and all that and then like
it was just crazy
and then he didn't he couldn't get to my
neck and slice my throat like i don't
know what the whole
the whole point in that was but i was
just like i didn't have no money or
nothing so it's
not like he was gonna rob me you know
like i didn't have nothing to take
and it's just like stupid to me but i
was really scared and
after that um i still did what i did but
like
i slowed down a lot because of my
daughter honestly
i'm turning my life together now you
know how old were you when you started
i was 18 19.
how old are you now i'm 24. 24.
have you you've not worked with a pimp
never
never i mean well yeah honestly i have
yeah
i have before yeah but
um i'd rather renegade now
whatever you want to call it i don't
care i prefer that
independence yeah but do you still get
uh
like just do you guys still pressure you
to come up with some money on the street
i mean they always come to me because
i'm not the ugly girl you know what i
mean like they come to me regularly like
i don't even try to put myself out there
like that they just come up to me you
know what i mean
like i can't help it sometimes i'd be
like no get away from me
even if they're offering me money but
sometimes like all money is not good
money i've learned that
by this dollar sign on my face and i
been through a lot of stuff in my life
no but i guess my question was
does working as a renegade still cost
you money
are there something yeah my living
expenses yeah but i'm like from the
thugs on the street no not really
because i don't have to
pay nobody you don't yeah because some
of the girls do
yeah i don't yeah good for you i don't
put myself i don't really talk to too
many people i keep my circle small
always there's a lot of snakes out there
in the grass you know i got to keep my
grass cut low
well anyways and karma tell me about
karma
ooh karma is a [ __ ] sorry excuse my
language karma is a mother effer
you know is it hard doing this kind of
work and then dealing with that
not really because i don't do grammy
[ __ ] to people i don't do grimy stuff
i don't do dirty stuff to people anymore
i have but when you do dirty stuff to
people
it's like that karma comes back to you
you don't know which way it's gonna hit
you it could hit you
up down left right you know like for
real like you don't know it could be
good or bad
and my advice is not to do nobody dirty
a roster [ __ ] will come back to you and
we don't want that
so you you mentioned before he started
speaking
on camera about wanting to get out
why you know what when you get out of
this life yeah i do i do i want to raise
my kids i don't want my daughter to grow
up like me
you know because my life was hard it was
hard but not
too hard other people have it worse i
need to really look at my situations
and other people's and my situation is
not that bad as other people because i
still have time to get my stuff together
you know did you finish high school no
i'm working on that now
and what would you like to do you're 24.
i'll have to do nursing
that would probably be a better
lifestyle than doing this yeah
honestly you will especially with kids
yeah yeah
everybody they're young they're babies
too you know every day you go out every
night you go out
not really i don't go out every night
every time you work you're risking
yeah taking big chances that's gotta be
a big concern
yeah you get depressed sometimes
no i don't cry a lot only when [ __ ]
builds up a lot you know
and then i and then i cry other times i
just pass out on somebody
like my boyfriend of all my ex whatever
he broke my phone and stuff you know so
like he's an [ __ ] he don't want me
doing nothing stupid
and illegal for money and he rather me
get a job but i feel like i'm
independent and i don't want to depend
on him anymore
so i said [ __ ] him and i left because he
broke my phone so [ __ ] him i haven't
talked to him since
your relationships with men have they
been have you had problems in your
relationships with men
yeah i think he's gay that would be a
problem
yeah like i don't know he has a friend
this this
boy or whatever he's a white boy but my
my ex he's black whatever
and he works like that at cbd warehouse
whatever thingy but um
anyways like he tried to help me
and have me work and label boxes
like um packages and [ __ ] and his friend
worked there too and they're like this
but he's like always trying to blow me
off for his friend and [ __ ] and i feel
like he's gay
low-key and like i don't know i'm just
over it
where would you like to see your life in
5-10 years um me having my own
mansion or something or a condo
or a a two-story house
my kids maybe have more kids and
have my dream car which is uh i don't
know what car yet
so where are your kids right now my kids
right now
are in the system
of san bernardino and i'm working on
trying to get my kids back
and i'm doing what i got to do and i'm
gonna keep doing it
and drugs tell me about that um
i mess around here and there that's my
problem of getting my kids back
because i test positive when i have my
daughter of
um crystal meth
whatever methamphetamines but honestly
i know how to handle it i know how to
handle it and i know how to stop
it's not like it's oh my god like oh my
god i need it you know what i mean like
it's not all like that at all
you know like straight up it's not what
does crystal must do for you
it takes my problems away for the moment
but when that moment's gone
my problems come back it's not worth it
really it's hard to stop kinda but you
know what
you just gotta be strong and have faith
either my kids or
the men and the meth is not
worth more than my kids my kid
means every my kids mean everything to
me and
i just wanted to get my life together
and just stop everything honestly
you know just got to surround yourself
around positive people that's it
in your relationship with your family
how's that it's good i talk to them here
and there
just keep it short you know
what's the most difficult part of your
life the fact that your kids are my kids
being gone kids are gone yeah pretty
much that's gotta make you crazy right
yeah is it mom
yeah it was the best time of your life
um my 18th birthday i went to vegas and
got so faded
and what's been the worst time
um thinking about my kids
what is it about this lifestyle that
keeps you stuck because
you you seem to like i'm not stuck
it's just not being not being able to be
with my parents and live with my parents
because i always want to walk on
eggshells you know what i mean
um i think that's the only thing keeping
back me having to walk on eggshells but
still having that respect for my parents
you know what i mean
i don't have to live with my parents all
the times just by running into [ __ ] up
people
you've been in love before how about
what didn't love
yeah my the one i loved he died
yeah he lived in compton he got stabbed
he still got the gambling shacks and
[ __ ] and they just
he started taking all my money and
gambling and all that and when i got fed
up with it because he wasn't doing [ __ ]
and i was taking care of us
and like he would just gamble all my
money our money whatever
my money really if you want to get
technical
and yeah pretty much just got tired of
it you know
it's tired of everything ah yeah
so when these guys ask you to do these
extreme or dangerous
things with them
you you you have
regrets later about no i don't ever
regret nothing else
i never do it well you never do it i
wouldn't do it if i ever had to regret
it
so you do it but you just move on yeah
what about stds and stuff like that no i
never had
never had anything no you're lucky
what's the most important lesson you've
learned or have you
stay protected
your contradiction darling yes my
daughter came along
i didn't plan that didn't want it but
you know
poor baby downs to be here
all right cassie well thank you so much
for talking with me thank you so much
nice seeing you guys wish you the best
of luck in turning your life around
thank you
sorry oh so nervous
oh my hair so ugly